we're due for a good bonding session
it's like the end of an era
we're all gonna get through this it's
emotional any tears over it
yeah it's kind of sad to see it end
we're so excited
you brought joy to so many people for so
many years you have just
launched this youtube channel hi
everybody and welcome back to my youtube
channel
and you know what today we are
in the glam room with caitlyn jenner why
was now the right time to launch a
youtube
channel and get some new content up
there well
you know during this pandemic i i've got
to stay busy
and i got to do something and actually
i was thinking about doing it and then
sophia had a conversation
with chris and chris goes you know
caitlyn should start a youtube channel
and i said
well yeah i've been thinking about it
and she kind of motivated me to say okay
let's try it
kylie has one she had all the contacts
we contacted youtube they liked the idea
and anyway it started and
it's been a lot of fun this was actually
a little bit of a family affair
chris gave you some advice on this
actually and since it came out the girls
have all called me and said oh my god i
love what you're doing this is great
you know and we're going to be doing
some things in the future
social media has become so big obviously
and there's nobody bigger than my family
agreed agreed literally no one yes
and uh they've used this format
magnificently
and um a lot of times in like
on instagram or this when things come up
whether it's
family issues maybe trans issues
personal stuff things that you're doing
those formats are very short
the youtube gives you the opportunity to
go more of in a long format
and so i've been able to do a lot of fun
stuff actually i'm really looking
forward to it saturday night
i got almost all of the girls from i am
kate
coming to dinner at the house oh you got
to film that
and we're shooting that and i'm so
looking forward to it because that's
where that show started
at my kitchen table when they came out i
had never met anybody who was trans
i couldn't i you know and that was my
first meeting with all these girls and
we wound up going on and doing the show
and i just want to see where everybody's
at now well you spent years being filmed
and then being edited how does it feel
to
have a platform that's kind of at your
control where you're
filming and you're choosing what you
want to put up there i like it so much
better
i like to be able to control my content
i watched your video where you were
looking back at the keeping up with the
kardashians episodes what was that like
for you to take a trip down memory lane
i have the greatest home videos in life
and
it's been so much fun to watch like
kendall and kylie grow up on the show i
mean i think kylie was like nine
kendall was 10 11 when it started and
to watch them grow up basically on
camera
um yeah it's pretty sentimental and now
everybody
has gone their own direction have their
own lives
i'm still involved but it's just not
like it used to be
and that's the sentimental part the show
was the best at keeping the family
together
to dealing with issues i have to say i
had some of the best conversations with
my children on camera
it kind of forces you a lot of times as
a parent
you put it off i have to ask how you
feel about it ending they just announced
this the show is ending
i talked to all the kids i talked to kim
yesterday i talked to him and
they have done such a magnificent job
and taking that show and building their
own careers
outside of the show i mean look i mean
kim has done just such a strong business
woman chloe courtney
uh kendall and kylie you know they have
their own careers right now
and they use that format so well that
there's a
million things to do you know um
and so i think in some ways they might
be a little bit relieved
that you know it's it's over with but on
the other hand
it was such a great format for the
entire family
we'll all we'll always miss that you
know
we're talking over 500 episodes
20 seasons i mean by far they've built
the most
the best reality series ever in history
you know
i mean it's epic yeah what do you think
it was
why now i just think everybody where
their life was
kendall's got her modeling career
kylie's got her business
you know kim's got two businesses you
know kkw
and uh skims and chloe's got her
businesses and this and that
enough is enough i think it was just
like time you know what
we did it phenomenal success
let's move on and do the other things
we're doing i mean kim's working on her
law degree
i mean the list goes on and on and on
yeah well it's a tough call because on
the one hand they're so good at managing
everything and you guys all are and then
on the other hand i get why they might
need some relief
i mean a lot of fans felt like
especially with courtney they were
watching and courtney seemed ready to
move on
i'm taking a break from the show now i
can focus like and plan
my time of being a mom cortis felt like
she wanted to move on for a much longer
she was probably the first one to say
okay i've done this i've got my other
things going on that's what kind of
inspired me to do the youtube channel
actually i got some really fun stuff
with kylie coming up i have talked to
her and i think she will
she's already agreed to do it but i
haven't shot it yet
kylie doing my makeup and then for her
youtube channel
i do her makeup i love this so much
amazing yes
here i am i'm doing her makeup on a
billion dollar face
you know it's a little scary kim even
talked about doing the cooking shows do
really well come over to her house and
we'll cook dinner you know for all the
kids and stuff like that
you were a part of kardashians for so
long will we see you pop in in these
final seasons at all it's a secret
can't tell it would feel wrong if you
didn't
don't be shocked if i do show up but
we'll see
i would bear at the beginning i would
like to be there at the end yeah
have you talked to chris about that i
can't say that
well you said she's helping me we're
gonna have to watch can i ask when you
got the news that it was ending who was
the first caller text about it ending
the first one was kim you know she's
kind of the leader of that family
i had dinner at kylie's house last night
and we talked a lot about it
um and uh
but everybody's okay it's like the end
of an era
yeah and that show brought our families
so
close together i mean the vacations we
took were so much
fun
[Music]
my diamond earring came up in the ocean
and it's gone
there's people that are dying places we
never would have gone
all together you know and
it's just great memories you know it was
it was good stuff it was a fun run
you know it sounds like you and cam and
maybe you and kylie had kind of an
emotional conversation about it
yeah we did um yeah chloe was there
yeah it's emotional yeah any any tears
over it
yeah it's kind of sad to see it end but
you know um we'll all be okay who's
maybe hit the hardest bite who might
miss the show the most oh
good question chris
yeah chris i don't know what's she gonna
organize now
you know she's got 10 million things up
in the air kids careers this that
you know uh she might miss that it's
gone
you know and uh uh but
i'm not worried about her she's doing
just fine which of the kids do you think
would be most likely to be on tv again
chloe
because she's just good yeah she's just
good she's such a piece of work
yeah and i can see her doing something
else
you know um yeah she would be the one
courtney's got her own thing she's got
all the kids she's got her own business
bush and kim is you know got all these
kids
working her butt off doing all these
different things
where chloe i i think with her
personality
uh she could do just about anything she
wanted to do you know uh
all the inner workings and what great
business uh women
everybody is so could there be another
deal a
show with streaming something on a
netflix what do you think there'd be a
deal lined up
i think for right now the closest you're
going to get is my youtube channel
because i want to keep the kids involved
you know
i do so many different things you know i
mean i still
race cars here we are
i got beauty tips i go a little bit
right here
a little darker i get rid of that
jawline we got cooking cook up the
garlic not too much i got a wide variety
of things to do
which um i'm kind of interested to see
on my subscriptions
on what they like the best do you see
this next chapter of you guys's life as
just enjoying that family time and the
grandkids how's that been
for you i have been very blessed i have
a lot of grandkids technically 18
grandkids okay that's a lot of kids
i want to figure all the kids you know
and highlight them because i think
they're really shining examples
of this generation coming up who have
um may not have been in front of camera
all the time
but have really done extraordinary
things with their life and i'm very
extraordinarily proud of them
do you think they'll carry on the family
legacy of being on tv one day
i'm a firm believer in finding
that one thing in life you know
um that when you find it the world
changes
i hope these kids find out what they
love
so when they get up in the morning
they're excited about the day
they can't wait for the day to start
because they've got
the perfect picture to paint as you just
said
chris now has a missing business hole
in her life just come in and help you
skyrocket the youtube channel
yeah no she did help out just kind of
get the
beginning of the ball rolling you know
and making the right contacts with the
right people
which she's obviously very good at
you guys as a family are such an example
of this of people
who are co-parents getting along with
each other and and being in a good place
yeah
um you know because a lot of times that
is not always the case
yeah um but um you know chris and i
um because of the family and the kids
we've been able to
stay pretty close i mean i think we're
closer now than we were
a year or two ago by the way the last
time i talked to you i asked if you
would ever join
as a possible next venture real
housewives of beverly hills
i remember you yeah yeah i remember that
then of course that went all over the
media
oh now is is there any update on that
and also now
now that chris is free people are saying
maybe chris should join it what do you
think
i think chris could get in with those
girls and mix it up and have no problem
whatsoever
much better than i can i'm not into all
the drama
you know with all these women are into
you know can you
um but chris i think chris would be
phenomenal on that and plus
you know she's friends with everybody
she knows everybody
and you know lisa rennes are like one of
her best buddies so
i think it's a much easier time for
chris oh my gosh by the way i mean you
want to talk about a relationship we've
watched over the years
courtney and scott what do you think do
you want to see them ultimately get back
together will we see that happen in the
final season
i don't know um i would hope he can kind
of get his act together
and they've got all these kids together
you know like courtney and scott
are both good parents you know whether
they work it out themselves and
um for a lasting relationship i don't
know
that's a courtney question do you see
yourself or or
any of your kids doing a spin-off doing
another show you guys
spawned how many spin-offs over the
years i think right now everybody's
going to take a big breather chloe was
you know picked the number one reality
star in the country
um yeah i'm sure there's other things
that she would like to do
um and so uh yeah
i don't think you've seen the last of
the family
i keep asking you about the girls but
but rob as well
how's rob doing do you think we'll see
him on the show more near the end
uh i hope so rob was an integral part of
the show
he's kind of stayed out of the limelight
for the last uh
few years uh which is fine that's his
own prerogative
i have seen him uh he's been doing much
better
you know and i'm happy for him i know
you and you and kanye were close over
the years have you talked to kanye
lately how's he doing
uh i haven't talked to kanye in a while
he's been living up
in wyoming
i have always loved kanye he has
been so good to me even going through
everything i went through five years ago
he was like my biggest supporter in the
family you know
and i'll never forget that it's been a
wild summer in a wild time how have you
held up during everything all in all in
the quarantine how have you been and how
are you and sophia both doing
at first the quarantine was really tough
uh now it's kind of
wearing on you um you know because it's
just been a long time
the good news is is i've made myself
busy
you know by starting this channel
shooting things
editing things putting things together
so i feel like i'm doing something
uh i have actually a few things coming
up
i have uh i can't say too much about it
but i'm doing a little pilot for a
sitcom
you're starring in it well i'm i'm in it
yes i'm in it with a friend of mine who
wrote the script and this and that so
yeah uh i'm gonna i'm gonna shoot that
we're kind of doing it down and dirty
because of all the restrictions right
now with sag and aftra
um but uh yeah in about three weeks
uh i'm gonna shoot that you know it's
only a couple days of shooting
but it will be fun then they're gonna go
out and try to sell it we'll see
but it's something different into acting
for you is it comedy is it drama
oh it's all comedy wow
yes i love comedy we're so excited that
you're still bringing us this content it
sounds like you have some awesome ideas
and uh you've brought joy to so many
people for so many years so i
i'm excited to see what you do next i
want the channel to be
fun but also motivating you know um
yeah so uh i'm looking forward to it we
got a lot of things going on
you